damit werde das hollywood-paar demi
moore hat vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
murats ernsthaft dass die videos die
videoreihe heißt ja kochen und backen
auf geringem bildungsniveau und habe mir
gedacht so wer passt geringes
bildungsniveau besser als der juni so
das ist mein ich hab dann umgebracht
das ist ein freund von mir
der grüne ist hesse und zwar er kann
auch er kann weder kochen noch packen
aber er ist hesse und ihr kind auf den
spruch was die schwaben nicht fressen
pressen die hessen und kuchen kriegen
und wieder hilft mir jetzt beim beim
kochen und beim backen und heute man
ganz ganz tolles rezept das kriegt sogar
der gewinn und zwar mache mir pizza
frikadellen linie ist christin oder ja
natürlich
und exakt juni wird jetzt mit seinen
zwei gehirnzellen hier die paprika
schnibbeln während ich das hackfleisch
vorbereite ja ja wir fahren oder dann
fangen wir an
das rezept habe ich im kopf ja das habe
ich im kopf und wir fangen jetzt an mit
den zutaten dafür will 500 gramm
hackfleisch zwei fleischtomaten dann 100
gramm champignons 125 gramm bis
mozzarella dann haben hier ein esslöffel
öl dann haben wir hier ein
eine paprika in zwei hälften geschnitten
dann haben wir hier zwei esslöffel
paprika pizza gewürz 1 esslöffel salz
und zwei toast scheiben zwischenzeitlich
simons handschuhe an
wie dann auch schon handschuhe angezogen
was manchmal als allererstes machen wir
natürlich die die frikadelle genau wie
frikadellen hatte ich auch schon gemacht
ja ok was brauchen für die privaten
natürlich hackfleisch das können wir in
die schlosserei man richtig weh genau so
haben sie nicht wissen rein gemacht das
brot das thema einheiten gingen wie so
ein schwamm kennst dich aus du bist auch
wieso ein schwamm
auf jeden fall haben wir das hackfleisch
und ihm das hackfleisch tun wir dieses
pizza gewürze und zwar ist es richtig
cooles pizza gewürz erste mal auf die
pizza so nochmals drauf gemacht dann
nimmer als nächstes das sonnenblumenöl
und man ist sondern im reit richtig
genügt zu sagen kannst du einschlagen
ich bin mir dann haben wir hier die
paprika und die paprika die tun mir in
würfel schneiden
um die paprika ein wirklich zu schneiden
das kannst du machen so wie es ist ganz
ganz einfach und zwar hat chris ellis
hat wie immer alles ein gerät und zwar
haben wir hier den alligator weil ich es
geht ja ungefähr muss man das besonderes
wissen meine paprika das besondere an
der paprika ist an dieser geben jetzt
haben wir hier das hackfleisch und es
hat gleich werde ich jetzt mit meinen
händen bearbeiten und wie gesagt er
genießt ein sehr sehr guter freund von
mir und iss nicht die hellste leuchte in
der rat war man schon bekannten freuen
genau wie man also jetzt möchte ich
dieses hackfleisch bin ich hab's
vergessen kann es mindestens noch
reinmachen ja so super wichtig genau das
ist ein richtig tolles hat gleich
richtig meint es richtig mini obst
finger drin so so und zwar wie gesagt
wir beleidigen stetig und unter uns
freunden genießen und ab schädel so
richtig wie nie
wir wollen ja deshalb was animalisches
mich nicht jetzt könntest du dir die
paprika würfeln bin ja
sie ist gewürfelt ja wahnsinn ich habe
es noch nicht ich habe immer nur stetige
master auch kleine regal ist mir egal
einfach nur unterdrücken es kann zur
wartung jetzt die jetzt die die paprika
würfel hier mit rein
und ich wusste jetzt mit eingenähten
möchte ich mein grüßen könig mal ist
jetzt pause von menschen sehen jetzt
auch ein gesicht du bist ja auch in der
öffentlichkeit einen hinein ich möchte
nicht dass die leute wissen dass wir uns
kennen das okay in der zwischenzeit
hatte grünes toastbrot eingeweicht das
kriegt er nämlich hinrichs mal ist
toastbrot und zwar warum aber ist auch
mal was zusammen haben genau ich weiß es
aber ich frage mal ein wenig genau ich
teste die nie auf so richtig einknicken
- ein gefallen tun ich meinen die leute
kennen dich nicht und schauen auch
hingekriegt umschauen so du darfst mich
beleidigen ja nicht irgendwas wegen
meiner herkunft mich nicht
diskriminieren ja und außerdem irgendwie
minderheiten beleidigen ist auch ganz
wichtig dass man darauf keinen spaß dann
wieder recht so perfekt jetzt genau in
der zwischenzeit hole ich das backblech
bin ich mache jetzt ist sie meine
handschuhe aus okay ich heiße es mal ein
backofen vor und ich zeige ihnen wie das
aussieht mit backofen vorheizen ist der
wahnsinn konnte man schon mal hier ich
mache den backofen an
es ist ein jetzt gehe ich auf heiraten
und zwar brauche ich um luft und zwar um
luft ist so unterschiedlich die heißluft
heißt no go perfekt so heißt es ekelt
sich vor auf 200 grad sagt sagt 205
statt
so der grüne ich fand jetzt die die
frikadellen bringe du kannst du ruhig
etwas größer machen denn wenn die
frikadellen nach dem backofen sie den
schwung für die zusammen kennst du das
es ist wieder ein gehirn was du auch
mein papa das letzte mal da auf jeden
fall stufen die backofen auf erbsen
größe genauso wie genießen
schön dass du da bist wenig freut mich
so was können wir eine notiz war das
letzte mal dran so minimal 46 prima denn
wir sind selbst schon zwei jetzt braucht
es noch vier
nein es gibt nicht einmal wie groß die
schon sind gut ab schädel gekrönter
mache weiter eingehen ja ok aber jetzt
aber sechs stück brauchen wir so und in
der zwischenzeit in den juni
hier ist eine frikadellen rollt weil er
nichts anderes kann bereite ich schon
mal das was drin weiß bereich vor was
eine tastatur die garnituren ist
garnituren ist das gar nicht ja warum
hat mir das gar nicht nur wenig sondern
blamiert genau das kann ihr okay dann
holen wir uns ein messer und zwar habe
ich ein ganz spezielles messer jedoch
nie was es hier ist weiß es einfach
nicht schaffen eine holzschachtel
richtig was befindet sich in diese holz
schafft ein damals besser so und wisst
ihr was ist besonders an damaskus es
bisher meist du bist weißt du das weiß
ich so was kommt aus damaskus und mich
ist mit diesem damals messerblock mit
diesem messer werde ich jetzt die was
wenn ihr mitmachen klinik die paprika
schälen da hab ich ganz kurz schneiden
wahnsinn oder hast du gesehen der strunk
entfernt habe für das kleine genommen so
jetzt werde ich die paprika und beim
schneiden ist ganz ganz wichtig
folgendes und zwar das ist so ein skill
was er jetzt zeigt es an kochs dass man
gar nicht weit hoch gelobten sondern
immer nur so mal so wenn doch das ding
am kap horn nein ich möchte den leuten
zeigen dass wenigstens gemacht die bahn
ziehen oder klar
da sieht es aus wie bei einem profikoch
ramsauer so und dann gehen wir dann mal
drüber der nikolaus jetzt habt ihr
gesehen wie schnell mal so und da machst
mainzer auch kaputt machen kann
jetzt habe ich das gewürfelt viel
schneller als mini mit seinem alligator
wahnsinn oder was man als nächstes
tomaten okay jetzt haben wir hier die
paprika und selbst noch nicht erwarten
was waren tomaten würfeln ja okay also
über die tomaten schneiden strom wird ja
genau stromkreis schneiden bei tomaten
ganz ganz wichtig so warum augenstein
mit den strunk aus
wisst ihr dass wir wahrscheinlich schon
gefragt du ja wenn er so hat ist genau
so sehe man die tomaten in hälften
gemacht hat aber noch einmal so
man kann natürlich auch die tomaten
würfeln wenn die tomaten hart genug sind
kann man sie hier in den alligator 1
machen jetzt dürfen wir die tomaten
einfach rein und so mag das wollten wir
ja stimmt kann schon mal würfeln müssen
ich wollte nur zeigen wie es nicht
gemacht mach das bitte nicht nach macht
es so wie es gerade im juni gesagt hab
ich einfach würfeln ich würd's nicht
machen
jetzt gehts cds zu machen jetzt richtig
ich habe das in wiligrad gesagt jetzt
machen sollen und es funktioniert
die tomaten gewürfelt als nächstes wird
ab juni die dann den büffel mozzarella
ja das besondere an höfen monster ist
das weiß ist jemand weiß ist weißt du
das weißt du dass keiner weiß es genau
richtig gummi hat recht es von düffel so
genau das werde ich jetzt nicht
kommentieren jetzt brauchen wir noch ein
tuch ich wollte zum tuch bühne gibt den
mozzarella schneien
die champignons werden wir in
zwischenzeitlich auch verarbeiten wir
werden sie nicht schälen werden sie nur
abputzen und es waren wir nicht
champignons nur abgeputzt den schnee mit
mond wegschneiden wegschneiden wären es
nur so das kam so wir reißen den schnee
weg den steg am essen
den gebe ich meinen schwiegereltern ich
putze wieso muss man die pilze
eigentlich ab warum wenig umwelt gegen
den salmonellen wo es nicht so
weitergeht
folgendes ist jetzt auch wir vom juni
weil damit nur dann daniel okay
zwischenzeitlich seien der kini hier
versucht den mozzarella zu schneiden
werde ich diese führung nicht mir das
paradies oder seines pc tabellen des
afrika die entschuldigung wenn man diese
frikadellen die mit liebe geformt hat in
den backofen schieben
juni die dreijährige kann die dinge
besser formen als juni wehrmacht dort
tun
allerdings ist vorgeheizt normal sagt
auch bei 20 grad einfach weitergemacht
wir haben ein essen die prägestätten
soll
hier leben die champignons angreifen
sollen sie ja auf jeden fall werden wir
folgendes machen im rezept wieder ändern
zwei esslöffel öl und zwar zu dem essen
in die frikadelle keine ahnung warum
aber ich brauche nur ein esslöffel öl
für die um die champignons anzubraten
die jungs vielleicht ganz ganz einfach
anbraten
dafür nehme ich ein paar eine bratpfanne
nämlich diese tolle bratpfanne hier ein
esslöffel öl reine ganz wichtig ohne
ohne öl niemals eine bratpfanne an
machen warum warum macht man das
warum macht man öl in die pfanne und
nicht einfach ohne öl anbraten
weil die partie trotz kaputt geht jetzt
hat hier ja wirklich es gibt auch an die
hauptgeschichte der fahrertür braucht
kein öl zum einfachen schritten haben
einfach alles nicht wieder fragen was
ich erzähle sie einfach nicht jedes ja
ok folgendes jetzt nehmen wir diese
champignons scheiben und tun sie
anfragen dazu müssen natürlich ein herd
an machen ganz ganz wichtig so dass sie
herangemacht gehen hier auf stufe 5
langsam erhitzen warum langsam angeht
sind weiß ist jemand ganz einfach weil
die panne sonst im bogen krieg die
fetten bauch so die dicken bauch und
zwar so wie die queen
folgendes ist die panne sagt kraemer
bisschen rum
es war nur kurz
die panne ist und jetzt können wir die
champignons in die pfanne geben und dann
anbraten
ganz wichtig da kann man kleine
patienten weg so binder das richtig
gemacht das kann ich gut
also ich habe jetzt die die champignons
angedünstet der dap schädel hat die
würfel geschnitten und jetzt haben wir
ja dass das nennt sich das nochmal die
frikadellen zehn minuten bei 200 grad
umluft im backofen gehabt die wurde
jetzt raus und dann tun wir es belegen
kann ihre entschuldigung an capirossis
aus asien aus der sender aus einer
frikadelle und jetzt kann man skalieren
und zwar kündigt mal so machen die jamie
oliver schmid hinten meist richtig schön
[Applaus]
ok mit dem löffel und der knie tut das
jetzt mal schön garnieren
hör auf mit der mit dem medium mit
löffel in der tiefe und panne zu katzen
ja genau das macht die krise richtig
toll denn die hat es öfters gemacht er
hat früher jahrelang hast recht
ordentlich gearbeitet richtig damit
girls was genau dann macht es ganz toll
[Musik]
so hatte ich richtig gemerkt wirklich
hast du echt voll gemacht
[Musik]
es ist also das ist heißt es
was man als nächstes
doch die hände zum 8 dort hatte ich weiß
nichts davon
wie hier auch die ganzen in das ganze
hitze macht es doch alles wieder töten
doch im dorf als eine art internet den
bakterien da habe ich kurz so schön
drauf nicht zu viel und jetzt auch die
tomaten
genau macht doch keiner seite
und was meine seite schreiben wir haben
zu viel das heißt ich glaube es würde
auch reichen bei der menge nur eine
tomate zu nehmen und jetzt um das ganze
noch ein bisschen zu toppen immer diesen
genialen cremigen büffelmozzarella das
ist doch richtig schön verläuft wir
können natürlich auch den büffel
mozzarella
wir müssen nicht in würfel schneiden
juni die bühne hat das nur gemacht weil
er nicht mitgedacht hat schreiben wir
noch besser gewesen
du hast doch gesagt und in würfel
schneiden
jetzt noch ein bisschen italien liebe
das ist ein witz gewürzt machen noch ein
bisschen drüber
jawohl
zack zack
jetzt habt ihr gesehen bei uns ein
bisschen was übrig geblieben aber es
kann auch sein die paprika tomate war zu
groß deswegen ist verstehen wir sind in
waghäusel wir luftlinie ungefähr 15
kilometer
richtig ist das atomkraftwerk bei uns in
die gemüse immer etwas größer juni genau
verstorben der gegner hat ausstrahlung
ist kerngesund so jetzt immer dass hier
das backblech markt blech moment hier
basilikum genommen richtig passiert
populist oregano weißt du
unterschiedlichen war sie nicht mit
oregano ist ein mal ehrlich wie
unterschied dass sie komplett mit
geschenken und genau das ist es jetzt
nimmt das backblech und schieben danke
du nie ganz kurz gelegt so sieht's aus
auf mittlerer hitze einfach rein sack zu
und jetzt einfach zehn minuten drin
lassen
während natürlich alles im backofen ist
räumte gremium ich dann zusammen richtig
auf den backofen dauert auch zu machen
sonst zerfällt es kein kuchen also ja es
kann zu fallen manchmal auch nicht so
und jetzt mal noch weiter gehen wollen
wir schön auf dass wir keine drinks und
stimmen morgen nicht mehr kochen weil
ich habe schon öfters vor wenig ist wenn
ein tolles format mit dir kochen auf
geringem bildungsniveau im juni genau
ich zeigen die niemals zu machen hat ich
zeigen die ganzen spiels die ganzen
tricks rund ums kochen also ich war
jahrelang war ich in ein bergdorf im
kaukasus und zwischen bergziegen und
habt ihr einiges gelernt und es bringt
alles im griff was ich gelernt habe wie
hast du heute schon was im kalkulation
ja genau
für ihn gibt's eigentlich irgendwas
heute war schon von mir wo du nicht
bewusst ist was du heute gelernt hast
werden oder einen wissen wie ein schwamm
aufsaugen
man sieht hier mit dem stark aufgestellt
wie nie ja gesagt
zwischenzeitlich habe ich bin ich und
ich haben inzwischen aufgeräumt haben
das hingerichtet sorgen jetzt kümmern
dass aus der aus dem backofen holen
von banknoten ist ganze folgen ja so ist
es doch klappen ist ganz wichtig und ja
wir mal gespannt schmeckt billig
es ist ein ganz ganz einfaches rezept
normalerweise machst das rezept gegen
zehn minuten ohne wartezeit genau
provinz gezogen darunter sind länger
ausgehen wirklich auf dem teller neben
tools karte drauf kommt die hier sind
männer
wir machen das ziemlich unkompliziert
sorgen probierst du als erstes wir
lassen wir erst mal probieren wenn
nichts passiert dann mache ich weil ich
bin wertvoller wo ich ehrlich sein und
sich gut schmeckt dann sagst du den
leuten manchmal sie es nach 100 schmeckt
ihnen nicht
dankeschön als mich wirklich lecker was
man noch machen könnte ist folgendes man
können zum beispiel noch zwiebel in
würfel schneiden auch andünsten und mit
rein legen also es ist auch mit kollegen
denken mit zwiebel haben wir extra etwas
machen jetzt hat er gesehen sogar einen
grünen bekommen das hin
mit wenigen zutaten das tolles zu
zaubern wenig begeistert von dir das ist
seit langem ein erstes erfolgserlebnis
seit der grundschule eigentlich wurde
bundesjugendspiele gewonnen hat
sie gucken während auch nicht okay nicht
mal das hat er gekriegt
juni aber ich toll super also wir werden
jetzt weiter aufräumen wir noch was
essen das kann man übrigens auch toll in
den burger bands reim machen dazu gibt
es ein tolles rezept mitbürger waren es
von den sally unterricht oder da machts
gut und beim nächsten mal wieder moral
fünf minuten manchmal geht es auch
länger mach's gut du hast keine freunde
genau erkennt keinen grüßen
dies macht es gut ich war echt gut
[Musik]